[Musique]
me suis pas joua le toit dit le renard
je ne suis pas apprivoiser
que veut dire ce mot apprivoiser ce mot
m'a interpellé pendant des années puis
un jour j'ai fait une rencontre
esmond a pris tout son sens
je crois que j'ai trouvé la réponse à la
question alors c'est cette histoire je
vais vous raconter
c'est l'histoire d'un élève qui
deviendra le mentor et le maître lui
deviendra l'élève avant toute chose il
faut que je vous ramène quelques années
en arrière quand j'étais petit j'étais
un enfant très solitaire j'étais un peu
associable très timide
alors j'ai passé le plus clair de mon
temps avec les animaux de la ferme avec
lesquels je noué une relation très forte
j'étais bien avec eux j'étais fascinée
par le monde de silence
et puis c'est à 20 ans que j'ai
rencontré celui qui allait devenir mon
mentor ou plutôt notre mentor avec
maïwenn magali on épouse plus tard je
les rencontrais la même période et je me
souviens de ce cheval celui qui allait
devenir notre guide spirituel donc ils
s'appellent thème de l'ado ma première
rencontre il est dans son box le regard
inquiet la lure fier et indomptable
il m'impressionne par sa réaction
violente de peur et d'insécurité mais je
suis fasciné par sa beauté sa présence
et par un grand hasard
il a fait partie de notre vie et à cette
époque là on ouvre avec magali une
écurie de spectacle on était jeunes
avions des rêves plein la tête et on
commençait à avoir beaucoup de succès
auprès du public avec notre équipe de
chevaux dont nous étions très fiers
commence à faire des spectacles
et bizarrement nous n'avions aucun
projet pourtant plateau il était là avec
nous mais ne se laissait pas dresser
pourtant cavaliers aguerris
je ne comprenais pas ses peurs ses
angoisses ses réactions violentes
il était sans cesse en train de défier
nos qualités dresseur et je ne
comprenais pas il arrachait tout ce
qu'il retenait régulièrement nous
arracher les longes des mains jusqu'à
nous brûler les mains et puis on passait
deux heures à le récupérer
j'étais un jeune cavalier il ya 20 ans
s'est remise en question ne sont pas
faciles que dois-je faire pour que tu es
un plat dos accepte d'être dressé je
comprends en tout cas qui me pousse en
mai extrême et me oblige à réfléchir sur
maria sur ma manière de lui demander les
choses il m'a fallu cinq ans pour que
s'opère un changement dans ma qualité à
l'aide du chiffre et tout doucement il a
commencé à se laisser apprivoiser
puis nous avons accorder nos violons et
nous avons dansé sur les plus belles
pistes d'europe
tous ces spectacles formidable qui nous
faisait rêver avec magali et au fur et à
mesure que notre relation se mettait en
place
je le ressentais à travers des
expériences marquantes dans notre vie
alors je me souviens de cette fois où
avec magali on décide de le laisser à la
retraite il avait 18 ans on a eu un beau
parcours une belle carrière ensemble et
on est parti au canada alors lâché
décide je dis je me dis que le voyage va
être long pour lui
alors qu'on lui organise une jolie
retraite à la maison mais les choses ne
vont pas se passer comme on le pensait
simple à doit fait une dépression l'a
perdu du poids
alors on l'a rapatrié au canada
il est arrivé sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de montréal de ma vie je n'ai
jamais vu un cheval aussi heureux de me
revoir
j'avais donc sous-estimer notre relation
à cette époque là on était sur un
spectacle de renommée internationale
cavalia c'était 60 chevaux en tournée
120 personnes un spectacle
extraordinaire
nous avons touché plus de 5 millions de
spectateurs à travers le monde est un
peu la donne est devenu la star les gens
faisaient des kilomètres pour venir le
voir
et puis il ya eu cette histoire qui a
été un tournant marquant dans notre vie
avec un plateau on était en stage au
nord de montréal entre deux villes et
puis là une dame s'approche timide il me
dit je suis désolé de vous déranger
j'ai un message à vous faire passer je
dois parler de la part de table à dos ça
m'a fait un choc
j'aurais pu la prendre pour une folle
mais je savais je savais qu'elle avait
raison simple ado lui avait parlé
certainement elle me dit il ne veut pas
rester aller à la clinique de
saint-hyacinthe à montréal il ne veut
pas mourir seul
il veut être avec vous en tournée et ce
cheval est malade les vétos ne lui donne
que deux mois à vivre
comment peut-on la mener est ce
raisonnable mais je savais qu'il fallait
que j'écoute un plateau je m'en voulais
je m'en voulais de n'avoir été aveugle
d'avoir été sourd à sa demande comment
c'était possible je suis une dame qui
vient de me dire ça il fallait que ça
change et ça a changé on appris d'un
plateau et on l'a amené en tournée avec
nous et là
et encore plus de cinq belles années
puis cinq années plus tard d'un plateau
décide de partir ce jour là je le sens
je le sais il m'a tendu j'étais en
tournée peu à la maison je le savais et
m'attendre et il allait bien je le lave
ce matin là sa longue crinière blanche
je laisse brut et devant la maison et je
m'assieds à ses côtés mais là j'ai un
pressentiment quelque chose de lourd
d'étrange
vous savez quand vous attendez un bus
qui ne va pas tarder alors le bus s'est
passé est un plateau est parti je le
regardais comme un élève à partir son
maître il n'était plus ce cheval sauvage
que j'avais rencontrés il ya 20 ans mais
je voyais comme un sage enveloppé dans
sa grande toge blanche
ils n'avaient plus peur
ce n'était qu'un cheval semblable à cent
mille autres et j'en ai fait mon ami il
est devenu pour moi
unique au monde alors quand tu aimes
l'ado est parti j'ai compris c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une page qui se tourne
c'est un livre qui se referme un livre
dans lequel chaque chapitre était d'une
intensité incroyable d'une expérience
d'enseignement unique
mais qu'at-il changé que s'est-il passé
pendant ces vingt années
ce cheval sauvage comment est il passé
ce cheval qui ne voulait rien entendre
de nous à cet ami apaisé complices
comment se sont opérés les changements
qu'il est son secret si les questions
qu'on se pose eh bien je crois je vais
vous décevoir mais la réponse est rien
il ne s'est rien passé ou presque rien
et c'est peut-être ça qui fait toute la
différence
je vous explique nous une face à nos
chevaux on a beaucoup d'attentes on veut
les dresser on veut les soumettre à
notre idéal on met de la pression on y
met des demandes
on veut que ce soit le meilleur élève on
veut d'en être fier on peut aller
jusqu'aux conflits au conflit s'il le
faut et c'est ce à quoi tu un plat dos à
résister
là j'ai compris nous humains
on est des boulimiques du savoir faire
mais on n'apprend pas savoir être et
pourtant toute relation se construit
autour de qui on est alors maintenant
quand je suis face à un cheval je me
pose la question qui je veux être à ses
yeux qu'il veut avoir face à lui il va
avoir un dresseur quelqu'un qui va
soumettre ses envies ses idées ou bien
va vouloir un ami peut-être un guide ou
un confident alors c'est ça que je
propose des tris quand je suis en stage
je suis confronté à des chevaux que je
ne connais pas alors je travaille sur
moi d'abord savoir être comment ça se
passe je me concentre je me recentre je
laisse venir les plus belles émotions en
moi des belles images mentales
je me sens bien j'ai créé le confort je
suis protecteur et j'invite le cheval
dans ma bulle
alors le cheval se pose la question se
dit qui c'est celui-là qui tout
doucement
il s'approche il a le choix mais quand
le cheval décide de venir vers moi et
qui me dit jouant ensemble c'est ça que
je veux dire apprivoiser une des grandes
leçons d'un plateau
ça a été pour moi quand je suis face à
un cheval de me demander comment je vais
être à ses yeux
mais avant ça il faut savoir l'observer
le regarder alors j'aime observer les
chevaux dans leur milieu naturel dans
leur relation entre la communication
quelque chose de formidable entre les
chevaux tout est simple tout est limpide
tout est clair un coup d'oeil un
mouvement presque rien tout se
comprennent
j'aime me plonger dans leur univers de
silence
et j'aime les ressentir j'aime les foi
se comprendre
très inspirant on devrait faire pareil
nos mains peut-être on devrait savoir se
taire de temps en temps alors j'ai cru
rendre la liberté à table à dos quand je
les laissais dans son pré pour lui
épargner les voyages et les rangs les
spectacles mais on ne parlait pas de la
même liberté parce que pour nous il m'a
la liberté qu'est ce que c'est la
liberté c'est les grands espaces sans
barrières sans contrainte
mais cette image idyllique de la liberté
pour le cheval c'est l'insécurité la
survie le danger potentiel
ils en veulent pas c'est pas ça leur
liberté ils veulent le confort ils
veulent manger ils veulent boire alors
je crois que j'ai laissé la liberté à
terme cadeau le jour où j'ai respecté et
qu'il était gelée respecter et je lui ai
laissé la liberté quand je ne lui
demandez rien mais je lui proposais
quand je lui demandais pas d'obéir et de
s'exprimer quand je vais demander ou
proposer de marché avec moi tout en
regardant qu'ils étaient ses humeurs ses
envies alors maintenant avec mes chevaux
j'ai développé une relation très forte
très particulière la relation c'est un
peu comme un un lien invisible qu'on
construit
quantis chaque jour et qui devient
toujours de chaque jour de plus en plus
fort une fois que ce lien est entre vous
vous ne pouvez plus faire comme si rien
n'était passé vous non plus vous ne
pouvez plus décidé de le couper et
chacun rentre chez soi quand vous avez
ce lien la force du lien vous avez des
responsabilités
par contre elle vous permet beaucoup ce
lien vous permet d'aller jouer avec
votre cheval d'aller vous exprimer de
lui demander des choses vous pouvez
négocier avec lui on communique
il s'agit plus dresser un cheval s'agit
d'interagir avec le cheval
rappelez vous cette phrase tu es
responsable de ce que tu as apprivoisé
alors tout cela on pourrait croire que
c'est du rapport homme cheval simplement
mais c'est beaucoup plus que ça je pense
que vous l'avez compris ce soir le
cheval pour moi et ma thérapie il m'a
aidé à être plus sociable moins timide
il m'a aidé à me poser à me connaître me
comprendre à regarder les autres autour
de - est depuis disponible travailler
sur mes humeurs sont ma patience et je
crois que
c'est ça qu'ils nous aident à faire
alors maintenant ma vie avec les chevaux
c'est des spectacles et des stages que
l'on donne à travers le monde des
voyages et des rencontres
je n'aurais jamais imaginé à quel point
le cheval peut nous permettre une telle
ouverture sur le monde et une telle
introspection sur soi même alors je
remercie les chevaux pour ce qu'il nous
donne d'humanité et maintenant je vais
vous demander d'accueillir le silence
et puis la prochaine fois que vous
rencontrerez au cheval vous ne le verrez
pas tout à fait de la même manière
sacré guillouche cheval qui est simple
on ne voit bien qu'avec le coeur
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]